le troisième et dernier message voulais
partager les coûts est plus rare
mais c'est celui aussi qui consistait à
21 semaines
nous sommes ravis ne sera pas sans
conséquences sur
le monde agricole et des finances
et
je l ai toujours aidé
[Musique]
la guerre est revenu en europe je me
disais cette guerre n'était faisait
littéralement par le président poutine
avec la situation humanitaire tragique
un peuple grévistes et une robe qui est
là qui résiste aux côtés du peuple
kenyan et il nous faut tout à la fois
essayer de bâtir la paix protéger mais
prendre aussi des mesures indispensables
pour ados apporter les solutions pas
existé
de manière certaine
il y aura des conséquences des
conséquences dans nos exportations
pour les grandes filières que vous
représentez et pour lesquels la russie
est elle née plusieurs autres pétards et
gentil dans ses dessins impact est sans
doute encore ont des conséquences nous
savons que sur les débouchés du vin aux
céréales et à beaucoup d'autres secteurs
nous aurons musée sera pas sans
conséquences sur le monde la cité de
l'énergie ce ne sera pas sans
conséquence sur l'alimentation du bétail
sont peut-être
la capacité à fournir et donc nous
sommes en train de matière et le
ministre le fera dans les prochaines
heures avec vous un plan de résilience
d'abord pour sécuriser pour 9 juillet
nos intrants
ensuite pour essayer au maniement de
bâtir des mots clés en termes de coûts
au niveau national et européen nous en
avons parlé il
l'ensemble de mes collègues et la
présidence en arrière et a tenté de la
cus par la durée
car
cette guerre sera une en sang des crises
qui aura dernière
il nous faut donc nous préparer avec
beaucoup de détermination
aussi beaucoup de solidarité
je voulais tout simplement
la
renseigne européen pour accompagner les
agriculteurs
pour construire les réponses de court et
moyen termes pour essayer de cette les
heureuses comme l'énergie et les
intrants pour accompagner en termes de
revenus et pour accompagner nos
compatriotes mais aussi sur les impacts
en terme de deux boucles
d'un niqab le
jour que cette guerre froide
le monde agricole c'est aussi pour
l'ensemble des membres de l'alimentation
mais en disant ce matin dessous vous
dire que les clubs organisation c'est
moi lisa sion et nationales européennes
soient là voilà ce que je voulais
simplement ça
n'étant à vos côtés vous dire
profondément pas passées comme
d'habitude les journées entières du coup
j'y serai de coeur croyez le bien le
beurre et la santé
vous avez
je suis attaché à sa portée représenter
et à ce cas derrière c'est à dire
une histoire traditions un attachement
de notre pays à sous sol à ses
productions ces valeurs
nous en avons le besoin vous en avez
besoin en eau heureusement
évoquant son que nous tiens monde quoi
qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il était
et je serai là avant que
aujourd'hui et demain comme l'était hier
il a répété nuls
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]